commercer à sète une plateforme de
redynamisation des commerces de
centre-ville
nous ça fait cinq ans et je pense que ça
fait au moins quinze ans que les
commerces ont beaucoup de difficultés en
centre-ville on connaît tous les raisons
des centres commerciaux ou internet et
ainsi de suite
une autre bêtise c'est de refaire venir
les consommateurs physiquement dans les
commerces
chaque ville va avoir une couleur un nom
un vrai identifiant pour créer une vraie
marque tous les commerçants de la ville
qui vont pouvoir y ait adhéré parce que
nous notre client c'est la mairie et la
mairie va mettre à disposition de ses
commerçants tout le système c'est à dire
la fidélité les bons plans le couponing
l'annuaire le click and collect alors le
consommateur lui avoir une application
qui parle au nom de sa ville on l'a bien
compris donc il va y adhérer très
facilement
et là il va retrouver déjà tous ces
commerces on va revoir la diversifier la
diversification qui a dans sa ville et
il va surtout pouvoir avoir de la
fidélité diaries va pouvoir consommer
dans chaque commerce de sa ville
gagnez des points et avoir des avantages
dans ces commerces des avantages et de
vraies réductions financières sur ses
prochains achats on est en contact avec
certains légumes depuis assez longtemps
mais le coc vide à accélérer les choses
évidemment
nous ce qui nous a intéressé dans saint
quentin en yvelines c'est que ces douze
communes
donc c'est vraiment la preuve que l'on
peut en plus de travailler sur une ville
travailler sur un ensemble de vivre le
village